some of obsessian welcome back to inside
Kona that's right thank you guys so much
and I I feel like appearance I know I'm
really late I'm sorry
oh hello I know I know true to Seattle
I've known Jesse since
[Music]
happening right here I'm gonna narrate
I'm a professional
um
yeah we have a chair soda please don't
okay
um so I'm gonna let them forage for
themselves podcast where Conan
interrupts other podcasts yes I heard
there was a podcast about myself
and interject about me uh I'm having a
wonderful uh salmon uh Curry Bowl yes
Andy Richter no
you have that disease where you think
you're Andy Richter I
um this gentleman this Joel McHale comes
stumbling by oh my God and uh I say
you've got to come right now and let me
show you our cool hangout space what do
you think of the new digs yeah uh
they're fine put the cans on
wait a minute wait a minute you put wait
a minute let me get this straight you
winch the trouble to put on a headset
and cans just to say it's fine just
wanted to make sure the velvety fog was
coming through my voice it sounds like
it is you can turn it even there we go
turn it down a little bit more
this is a beautiful building uh gorgeous
I'm very jealous of all your success you
should be uh it's really nice I don't
know it's really like uh one of the
nicer buildings on Larchmont and it's
really a of a neighborhood yeah
yeah you know what this building's in
foreclosure so we're glad you got in
what is this
I brought you in because I want you to
bid on it
we've made it terrible mistake
that's it comes with a gazebo yeah it's
a very um It's So Clean it's well made
it's like a Scientology hangout
that's weird
it's too nice I've decided I just turned
everyone seems to like each other which
also I'm suspect it's because you're
here everyone's behaving yeah
it's chairs go through the window when
you've been working with Sweeney since
the 60s please why would you upset him
like this I mean how it's so good so
that you guys get along so well well
Mike Sweeney I met him we had a radio
program that we did with Jack Benny yeah
there was no television at that point
there was no TV and here you are but
then when TV was invented uh we we
decided to make the most of it this is
this is great uh Jesse I haven't seen
you in a while I know and I was so happy
to run into industry but yeah you came
bounding up to me like a puppy I did it
was cool and then I gave you a treat
and I slobbered as I tend to I don't
know if you know this she got her start
at uh a little show on E called Dr 9021
kind of my first job in Hollywood I
didn't but yeah well your people did
yeah she was and she tried to stop it
you tried to stop I was like uh there's
a lot of aborted aborted fetus jokes in
this packet can we maybe dial back to
three
uh she was so funny that she smartly got
out
for a while and then uh then you came to
work for us that's right yeah so cool
and I mean literally this was two
thousand and seven yeah oh you're there
a while I was I was there I left and uh
there was a spin-off of the soup called
the dish that was for girls right
because the soup was only for men
in their 40s literally it was for women
in their 30s oh yeah right
um how did the dish do I don't know that
show the dish what was hosted by uh
Daniel Fishel who was Topanga from Boy
Meets World yes I remember that she got
Millennials in the house I watched that
that's like when you say LeVar Burton
and they're like Reading Rainbow and
you're like Jordy laforge
and then someone was like Kunta Kinte oh
Mike Sweeney is waiting for someone to
mention red buttons
anyone red buttons I'm amazed that
Sweeney went with the Henley today you
never see him in a long sleeve uh three
button shirt I'll show you some looks
okay that's okay we're good we're good
we're good I've
SUNY and I have been all around the
world together as I have with Jesse on
the Conan Without Borders episodes we've
been everywhere have you been to not
everywhere yeah not Seattle though yeah
well that doesn't really you and I have
hung out in Seattle yeah we totally have
that's where we met on the back the last
two rows of well I had met you on the
inside coming this is not a life
go ahead all right we're on Peter Teal's
jet
[Music]
appeared uh this was on the 12 30 show a
couple times yeah and then I knew you
from the from being on the show then
um but I was I married into Seattle yes
and uh literally yeah my wife lies is
from Seattle and so we were up were we
we were up in Seattle I think we were
for Thanksgiving I think or something
like that yeah uh we were you were in
the lab we were getting I was like oh hi
and I was very golden retriever-like it
at with you at the gate and then you
were the the last row of the Alaska and
we were the second to last yes it was an
Alaska Airlines flight you guys were the
very last row you and Sarah Liz and I
were the second to last row I think we
were also wrestling kids uh into various
yeah yeah oh they oh they knew what they
were doing
walking to the bathroom and they would
be waiting and then they would see Conan
and then they would you could see them
question themselves and be like it was
funny
snapshot there's this misconception that
celebrities are jetting around the world
in luxuries that Joel Michael and I are
hanging we are holding down the last row
of an Alaska Airlines flight Air
Alaska's first classes in the back yeah
and you can smell the uh disinfectants
coming out of the bathroom
that really that's now going back
12 years ago I think it was just that
muscle just held uh
um and then I remember your late 20s
thank you that's right wow no wonder
they hired you promoter promoted
I love I because I knew that you guys
were friends and it would it meant it
felt like somehow I had done it even
though I had nothing to do with it and
it wasn't I think you tried to drive a
wedge between us at some point because
as Conan would say stuff like you know
Jesse said a couple things about you and
then you tested the waters with what
that was yeah which was you just you
know you sometimes touch people too long
like the long hug he said that and I was
like that I could do that yeah I was
just trying to find out what's
acceptable I want to know who that guy
is oh that's Sean can you see him too
it's under there no he's dying in his
building did he you know what's so funny
Sean is crouching in the corner like
there's been a drug raid and he's hoping
no one knows and there's no cameras
this is nice this is I mean this is the
last thing you thought was happening
because you were headed were you headed
to your dentist or were you just running
oh I'm so I was supposed to pick up
Sarah at the airport
she's in the last row where is this it's
fine she's fine they have that guy the
Guy Fieri restaurant where you can get
uh almost anything chili yeah put in a
pla Burbank airport is the best it is
the greatest airport it's a good secret
airport people don't really a lot of
Alaskan Airlines was a secret airport
now once they hear this podcast don't go
it's still a secret leak I feel like we
should turn this podcast back over to
Sona to the guy in the corner what the
were they talking about it's a
little show because we're called uh
inside Conan where they explore behind
the scenes
all right let's me to it right now
yeah
it's pretty secret we're building are
you sure Arizona Was preparing for this
show with uh guacamole and I think there
was another kind of soup yeah yeah I was
eating with Sona when you walked up
Podcast appearances I take them very
seriously
yeah yeah well I think this was what you
just experienced now was it happening um
yeah this regular podcast was happening
when suddenly you know Conor Brown Joe
McHale comes smashing anything can
happen here right anything will happen
yes the guy I don't remember the time
you and I were having dinner together
and uh
we looked at that nightclub that you
were you were looking at a building on
the brand yeah I wanted to buy a
nightclub yeah at a nightclub but we
went to LA republique yeah we went to
the library just to grab a bite right
because we were looking for a space
maybe that was on purpose the phone we
found this space you two win on purpose
it wasn't just it was right after I did
the show and you were like Hey we're
gonna go look at the building you want
to come look and I was like well let's
look at a building yeah so he looked at
a building because we were is before we
found this space right looking for a
space we were there congregate I
remember that place before you say who
we saw but we saw somebody else there
two people two different people that
were like oh there's those people what
do you think moment well at the same
restaurant yeah because uh Allison Janny
was there with uh Phil feed Phil uh oh
yeah so they were there yeah and we
talked to them and they were doing a
podcast they were doing a podcast and
then we were sitting and then out of the
corner of my eye I saw a gold prospector
enter the restaurant and I like someone
with a beard a massive beard and there's
David Letterman and the next thing you
know we're sitting with him yeah uh he
kept coming over going like try the fish
and then he would hand the bread over
and everyone was like we have to go talk
to him
no no huge tree you know what I mean
like you're like
we're being invited over to and we sat
with them for four hours wait was not
four hours it was uh Dave Dave will tell
you it was not four hours he would not
tolerate four hours
I'll tell you in person because here he
is
[Music]
I remember you guys were talking and I
and then he turned to me and goes do you
just make noises
he's a fan yeah he was a big fan I think
he almost remembered who I was by the
end
I think that night you were also your
wife's waiting at the airport she was
like where yeah she's uh getting back
Joel yeah she was doing a lot of uh
piece work uh and uh boy she's exhausted
it's now 24 hour well I think yeah all
right I think Conan it's great to see
you dressed up for work
I'm
I did a workout this morning and I'm
wearing
sweatpants and a t-shirt but I thought
it's a podcast so I'm dressed like an
alcoholic at four in the afternoon uh
okay so my great think about your great
grandfather wore like nine different
kinds of Tweed probably and had a stick
yeah and walking through muck that his
feet were wet and he was probably
hurting sheep and a couple of
them I'm sorry
and then your grandfather he got on a
ship right because uh you know like
there was a potato famine this is also
you've done your reading they go to
Ellis Island like my like my
grandfather's last name was smidge your
Bakken and they were like what's your
last name and he was smidgeboxing like
it's Jackson now he's like sounds great
and he he my does my great migrated did
you know where they were killing the
sheriffs if you were in the go and then
my then all of a sudden like my dad
those you can come to your parents who
like oh they got a higher education they
became professors and then like then you
come up and cut to you in your building
wearing Leisure wear top of the world
can I say I I want to congratulate you
on joining the Army
uh this this is incredible this is like
going to the dentist office okay so what
you have your excuse for yourself
your ancestors would be proud or they
would be like how did like this was no
I'm saying it's such a cool thing I
usually just Jess is dressed like uh
well you have good style you have good
Style thank you that sounds like you
know you're on on you're being recorded
and you know I do know I'm being with
you and I respect you and I think you're
one of the no it looks doesn't look like
doll's clothing or anything like that
I'm just saying that if that if your
grandkids like wait six wait you guys
will be super like you have will have
done well and you're wearing what that's
that's okay
I'm saying I'm saying it as a compliment
I know everything that comes out of my
mouth sounds sarcastic but I'm saying no
it's like a success yeah no no it's a
terrible terrible insult all of us
um we're out we're gonna go I don't know
because I want Sona you get the hair out
of time
all right thanks to Sonoma Obsession
this was great thank you so much for
having me you guys